estamos en el problema número 11 y lo
padre es que me he adelantado un poco
para que tú veas que ya tengo aquí hecha
la tabla del problema número 11 así que
vamos a trabajar lo dice de acuerdo a la
tabla siguiente o ya la siguiente que me
falta velocidad relativa de los
that
relativa pela
espero que tú entiendas mi letra intenta
ser la mejor letra posible dice de
acuerdo a la tabla siguiente el aceite
de motor de un automóvil que se
clasifica en 5 donde un 10 w
15 donde un 20 w flujos a no sé mucho de
automóviles pero espero que así sea dice
cuántas veces es más rápido el aceite de
un auto con una clasificación de 5 w de
5 w que un auto con una clasificación de
20 w flujos cuántas veces es más rápido
un auto que tiene un aceite que tiene
clasificación 5 w que un auto que tiene
aceite de 20w bueno pues vamos a ver qué
dice aquí velocidad relativa a 5 w
después dice 10 w
la mitad de rápido que 5 w la mitad de
rápido que 5 w qué quiere decir eso
bueno que podemos ver que es 5 dobles es
exactamente lo mismo
dos veces es el doble de rápido que algo
que va 10 doble 1 que 10 w bueno esto
por una parte pero después me dice que
15 w 15 w es la mitad de rápido de lo
que va 10 w entonces podemos decir que
10 w es igual a 2 veces lo que va a 15 w
es el doble de rápido de lo que va a 15
w si 15 w es la mitad de rápido de lo
que va a 10 w pues puedo decir que 10 w
es lo mismo que dos veces el doble de
rápido de lo que va a 15 w ahora esto
por otra parte porque por otra parte nos
dice que 20 w
va a la mitad de rápido de lo que va a
15 w de igual manera yo puedo decir que
15 w and over poner sin 15 w es igual a
2 veces a 20 w porque es el doble de
rápido de una manera similar ahora yo lo
que quiero comparar son estos dos este
con este así que qué te parece si
sustituimos para arriba vamos a
sustituir esto aquí después esto aquí
para poder comparar 5w y 20w a ver aquí
tengo un 15 w y en lugar de 15 w voy a
escribir dos veces 20 w entonces me
queda que 10 doble uno es igual a dos
que multiplican a dos veces 20 dobles a
2 veces 20 w lo único que hice fue en
lugar de poner 15 w el valor
correspondiente en 20 w muy bien y
después ahora voy a sustituir 10 w lo
que vale 10 doble o aquí justo acá
dentro de esta ecuación me va a quedar
que cinco veces doble uno es igual a dos
veces que es este 2 no te vayas a perder
es justo este 22 veces a que multiplica
a dos veces que es este 2 este 2 lo voy
a poner de color anaranjado que por
cierto era lo mismo que este 2 de aquí
este 2 aquí ya esto lo voy a múltiple
por dos veces por dos veces que es a
este dos de aquí es este 2 de aquí que
por cierto es lo mismo que este 2 de
aquí que este 2 de aquí es tenemos y
este 2 de ahí salió que dos veces 20w
hicieron paréntesis cierro todos
hicieron tres paréntesis que quiere
decir esto que cinco veces w va dos por
dos por dos veces más rápido que 20 w o
dos al cubo veces más rápido que 20 w
inclusive podemos decir ya de una manera
formal que 5 w va ocho veces ocho veces
lo que va 20 w o dicho otra manera 5 w 8
veces más rápido de lo que va 20 w y
estás justo mi respuesta que por cierto
es el inciso c ahora tú podrías cambiar
las variables y en lugar de decir 5 w
poner x en lugar de 10 w poner james
aquí tendrás que poner
en lugar de 15w poner z y aquí en lugar
de 10w poner bien y aquí 20w sustituirlo
por am y aquí 15w 2 sustituimos por z es
exactamente lo mismo y trabajar con
variables que ya conoces pero bueno si
lo haces con mucha calma te vas a dar
cuenta que es 5 veces doble 1 es el
doble del doble del doble o dicho de
otra manera como 10 veces w 4 veces más
rápido que 20 w 5 veces dónde va a ir 8
veces más rápido que 20 w bien problema
número 11 vamos a ser el problema número
12 que tiene a una gráfica una figura
como ésta debe poner la tengo algo así
parecen tramos los semejantes tengo algo
así tengo algo
algo así
ok después tengo algo como por acá
algo más o menos así y me dan algunos
puntos a dejar de poner los puntos aquí
tengo el punto p
este es el punto cu y este es el punto
r
ok y qué datos me dan me dicen en la
figura siguiente dos puntos p
b están distribuidos de manera homogénea
a lo largo de la línea l esta es la
línea l y como están distribuidos de
manera homogénea eso quiere decir que la
distancia que hay de p a esta distancia
es exactamente la misma a la distancia
que hay de abel es exactamente la misma
de ave o de otra manera entre pib a es
el punto medio después nos dice y los
puntos p q r p q r están distribuidos
también de manera homogénea a lo largo
de la línea m está la línea m y eso
quiere decir que la distancia de quiaca
es exactamente la misma que la distancia
de aquí acá por un razonamiento idéntico
dice si pp es igual a 4 si pp de aquí
hasta acá es decir toda esta distancia
de aquí hasta acá es igual a 4 eso
quiere decir que esta distancia es 2 y
que esta distancia es 2 estás de acuerdo
si de aquí acá
y este es el punto medio entonces esta
distancia es 2 vista distancias 2 si pp
es igual a 4 y pr es igual a 6 de aquí
hasta acá hay 6 de aquí hasta acá hay 6
unidades lo que quiere decir que dp aquí
hay 3 y de kuwait hay 3 porque nuestro
punto medio y además de a hacu d
hay 4 unidades
hay cuatro unidades ok lo que me
preguntan es cuál es el perímetro del
cuadrilátero a q r b
q eres más déjeme ponerlo con otro color
y hablar de un cuadrilátero y creo que
este color nos va a servir el
cuadrilátero
q
r
ve
ok lo bueno es que ya sé que este
cuadrilátero tiene una distancia de 4
justo aquí de 2 justo aquí y de 3 justo
aquí lo único que me falta saber es
cuánto vale b r pero para hablar de pr
quiero que visualices dos triángulos voy
a hablar de triángulos
semejantes fíjate bien en estos dos
tramos en el triángulo que tengo aquí el
triángulo p a uno después también quiero
que te des cuenta que aquí tengo un
ángulo y este al mundo lo comparte este
triángulo cuando el triángulo grandote
el triángulo grande es el triángulo ap
de r
ven
en este triángulo grande este de aquí
va a ser
semejante al triángulo de aqu como puedo
decir que los dos son triángulos
semejantes bueno por una razón la
primera es que comparten el mismo ángulo
este ángulo lo comparten los dos así que
bueno podemos decir que el ángulo lo
comparten ahora fíjate en las
proporciones si yo me fijo el primero
pensemos en el triángulo rojo si me fijo
dos a tres es exactamente lo mismo que
decir a este lado grandote que vale 44 a
este lado grandote que vale 62 tercios
es lo mismo que 4 sextos y eso lo
sabemos y eso lo saqué de las
proporciones de estos lados estos lados
son proporcionales y como tenemos dos
triángulos que comparten un ángulo y
tienen lados proporcionales eso quiere
decir que son triángulos
semejantes y tú puedes puede ser
bastante denso analizarlo en algún vídeo
que tenga que ver con triángulos
semejantes y lo genial de tener unos
semejantes es que ya sabemos también
cuál es su proporción lo que pasa es que
de este lado a comparación de este lado
se duplica y de este lado la comparación
de este lado entero se duplica entonces
de este lado la comparación de este lado
entero se debe duplicar también si todo
se duplica en este triángulo entonces
este lado debe ser la mitad de este lado
y por fin ya tengo este 8 que era justo
que necesitaba la longitud debe ser por
lo tanto puede decir que el perímetro el
perímetro del cuadrilátero azul es a
82 + 4 + 3 lo cual es 17 y esa es la
respuesta a este problema si nosotros
hablamos de 3 modelos semejantes te das
cuenta de todo esto va a obtener que el
perímetro es justo 17 que por cierto es
el inciso
el cis o muy bien problema número 12 ya
está vamos el problema número 13 el
problema número 13 y puede ocupar este
color de aquí problema número 13 y de
hecho el problema número 13 y el
problema número 14 van de la mano así
que voy a poner aquí el problema número
14 y nos dan dos funciones nos da la
función nos dan la función gdn y hd n 10
más déjenme borrar todo esto para
ponerlas en un principio
gdn está definida de la siguiente manera
como n cuadrada más en ok eso está muy
fácil y hdn hdn está definido como n
cuadrada - n okey estas dos se parecen
bastante ahora sí hablemos del problema
número 13 y del problema número 14
problema número 3 el problema número 14
y el problema número 13 me dice cuánto
vale g de 5 - h 4
ok pues vamos a sustituir no está tan
difícil que de cinco metros que fijar en
nuestra función eso quiere decir que en
lugar de en voy a poner cinco y me va a
quedar cinco elevado al cuadrado más
cinco ya esto lo tengo que quitar h de 4
pero h t4 me voy a fijar en esta función
de aquí entonces menos voy a abrir un
paréntesis aquí este paréntesis este
otro paréntesis menos h de 4 y lo que
quiere decir es que sustituye a lo que
quiero hacer es sustituir el valor de n
por 4 no va a quedar 4 al cuadrado menos
4 ok vamos a ver cuántos esto a 5 al
cuadrado más 5 es lo mismo que 25 5
estos 30 a 30 le voy a quitar y después
tengo 4 al cuadrado menos 44 al
cuadrados 16 16 mil 4 es 12 12 y 30
menos 12 eso está muy fácil es 18 y es
mi inciso de de lujo esto está bastante
sencillo vamos a ver qué es lo que voy a
preguntar el problema número
14 déjenme cambien de color ok me dicen
a qué expresión es equivalente
h d m más 1 a qué expresiones sitio a
que expresiones equivalentes
htm 1 bueno pues lo primero que se me
ocurre es que utilicemos a la definición
de esta función h es decir que en lugar
de n voy a poner m 1 entonces h de m 1
es exactamente lo mismo que m + 1 esto
elevado al cuadrado estoy sustituyendo
el lugar de n a m 1 ya esto le tengo que
quitar a m 1 a esto tengo que quitar m
más
cuidado con los paréntesis y los signos
y cuantos esto
bueno pues m 1 elevado al cuadrado
déjame separar esto de aquí ok m más 1
elevado al cuadrado es lo mismo que n
cuadrada más dos veces el primero por el
segundo más 2 m más el cuadrado del
segundo esto es un milímetro cuadrado
perfecta lo sabemos hacer y creo que no
es nada difícil es muy importante que tú
te sepas bien las fórmulas del binomio
al cuadrado perfecto ya esto lo tengo
que quitar en nuevas 1 entonces va a
quedar menos por este menos por este me
queda menos m menos 1 ok y cuánto es
esto bueno pues aquí este uno con este
uno estaba aquí puede reducir la semes y
me queda encuadrada menos m m cuadrada
menos m
y esto es equivale esto es equivalente a
h d n quien saque de m bueno pues es m
cuadrada menos m utilizando la
definición de h entonces h de m uno
puedo decir que es exactamente lo mismo
que h d m y vamos a ver en los incisos
en los incisos no está
así que me equivoqué dónde está el error
qué pasó aquí a abrir hd en 1 m
+ 1 al cuadrado porque así está definida
la función h
- m 1 qué raro que habrá pasado aquí a
ver déjame borrar otra vez todo esto
porque si no nos vamos a confundir y no
voy a poner nervioso y no sé qué voy a
hacer y entonces todo puede salir mal
borremos esto ok
empecemos desde el principio hola soy
salman khan y estoy haciendo hd m1 y
cuantos hd más uno bueno pues esto hdn
más uno
si sustituyó en la función hdn es lo
mismo que m más uno elevado al cuadrado
menos m más uno está de acuerdo hasta
aquí creo que no he hecho nada raro ni
magia ni nada del otro mundo no sé
extraterrestre lo juro vamos a ver
este es un binomio al cuadrado perfecto
entonces esto de aquí esto es
exactamente lo mismo que me cuadrada
dos veces m más 1 el cuadrado del
primero más dos veces el primero por el
segundo más el cuadrado del segundo ya
esto le tengo que quitar esta parte de
aquí esta parte de aquí que es menos m
menos uno
ok de aquí este uno esté uno y este
menos uno se los puede cancelar este
será con este y después me queda que
esto es igual a m cuadrada
y 12m menos m es más m
hoy hay haya aquí estaba el error en
lugar de más posee menos hice una resta
medio rara aquí va más un siglo de más
no un signo de menos y ahora si no es lo
mismo que htm htm es igual a m cuadrada
menos m pero aquí tengo encuadrada más m
y si te das cuenta es gm o que yo creo
que la respuesta es g de m porque gm si
es m cuadrada más m justo así está
definida la función m si yo pongo en
lugar de n m me va a quedar en el
cuadrada más m ya ver si esto sí están
mis respuestas me preguntaban a qué es
equivalente la función htm 1 bueno pues
es equivalente a gm que es el primer
inciso el inciso a ok salió este
problema menos mal y bueno ya no me da
tiempo de hacer otro problema pero aquí
tengo el 3 el 14 y en el siguiente vídeo
seguiré con el 15